position yourself for success I've
noticed that people are best positioned
for success when they focus not just on
improving their skills but on improving
the right skills they also tend to be
acutely aware of two important facts one
is that everyone's an expert at
something often that something has
nothing to do with what you went to
school for or even what you've been
doing for however many years you've been
working away at a job everyone has
another scale or fountain of knowledge
perhaps hidden away or currently unused
that can be uncovered and developed in
pursuit of a different and more
profitable career goal the second
important fact is that if you're good at
one thing you're probably good at
something else even though your formal
qualifications may not be the most
relevant in the search for freedom
you've probably gained skills along the
way that can be repositioned or
redeployed qualifications show that you
can follow directions good job but
merely following directions rarely leads
to freedom skills show that you can get
something done and they are the keys to
finding success and happiness in your
life finding freedom requires you to
abandon the lines of reasoning that have
gotten you thus far
that's where mastering the right kind of
skills come in in any good Prison Break
movie that is usually a star and a
supporting cast of characters the star
who is instant of course is joined by a
motley crew of accomplices who all pitch
in the help and sometimes hinder the
hero's attempt to break out typically
each accomplice has a particular skill
there's a tool Smith who works in the
electric room and can fix anything
there's the guy with a degree in
pharmacology who can obtain sleeping
pills to the night watchman's coffee
there's a short small guy who can wedge
himself in the narrow spaces most of
these specialized skills and abilities
are not interchangeable nor are they
easily learn if you don't know how to
hotwire the prison's electric grid to
turn off the lights in the guard tower
you're probably not going to master this
ability in a short period of time for
most people access to a trove of
pharmaceuticals is hard to come by and
being short and small is a matter of
genetic destiny not something you can
simply will yourself to become so before
worrying about upgrading your skills
new ones it pays to understand what your
existing skills are step number one make
a list of things you do well create an
inventory of all the things you know how
to do each of these skills is valuable
and somewhat unique step number two
write down at least one thing you hate
doing and aren't good at your greatest
weakness will probably never become a
strength especially if it's not
something you care about improving with
both of these lists your goal is to
focus on what needs to be upgraded and
remember it's not necessarily the thing
you're worst at position yourself for
success